Meet the Korok family.
Two men and their three foster children.
Until now, adopting children hasn't been an
option for the gay couple.
In Germany, same-sex partnerships don't yet
have the same legal status as married couples.
"Our wish is for our union to no longer be
seen as a second-class marriage.
Not just to be registered life partners - but
to have a fully recognised, normal marriage-
where we have the exact same marital status
as everyone else.
If the German parliament votes yes on the
so-called "Marriage for Everyone" law, the
couple would be allowed to adopt.
They say that would be a win-win situation
for both them and their children.
"The opportunity to adopt children as your
own helps secure their financial future, as
it would with your own children.
Think about all the things that go with adoption.
Child custody is in the here and now -- but
adoption is connected to inheritance - future
financial security for the children."
Both men have campaigned for gender equality
for years.
But they say they're not grateful to German
Chancellor Angela Merkel for her sudden policy
turn around on gay marriage.
"What is being voted on is something we think
is self-evident.
It should've happened a long time ago.
I'll be happy if the bill passes, but in the
end, it's like getting something you feel
you've been entitled to for a long time."
In the future, Michael and Kai Korok hope
that the difference between homosexual and
heterosexual couples will disappear completely
– both from law books – and from the way
people think about relationships.